So, there's three reasons that
entrepreneurs do not succeed that are
not technical. So, what I mean is this.
I get questions a lot about tactics, and
I have tons of tactics, and I walk
through lots of videos, and you can
watch the other videos for that stuff.
But,
when I talk to entrepreneurs, and I
talked to plenty of them cuz we have
about, you know, we have people come out
every single, you know, week here in in
Vegas.
And and this is to be clear, not small
entrepreneurs. So, we're talking, you
know, 1 million, 10 million, 50 million.
That's kind of the range of the people
who come through uh our headquarters.
So, legit businesses, right?
The things that limit them are not the
tactics they seek.
And so, there are three things that are
that are required to be super successful
in any business.
And the reason that I think most people
cannot do it is because they are
anti-human.
So, who we are. And also, when you see
some of these really successful CEOs and
and and billionaires and whatnot, and
they come off almost robotic,
I don't think they started that way.
I mean, in fact, sometimes if you look
at some of my earlier videos, they I
seem less robotic there than I do now.
Um
that's not it's not on purpose. Um but,
the issue is this,
is that we as humans want new stuff.
We want it now, and we want it to be
easy.
And those three things are actually the
antithesis of what is required in order
to be successful in business.
We need to not do new stuff,
right? We need to keep doing the old
stuff. We need to not pursue shiny
objects, right? That's what focus is.
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> We have to be willing to delay
gratification and not get it now, but be
willing to work now, get no reward, and
hope that we will get something later.
And when we fail, which we inevitably
will along the way, we have to be
willing to continue uh and not question
our original
is it worth it uh to begin this pursuit.
And so, when you back that out, the
three I would say character traits,
which we'll just say behavior patterns,
how you behave in a number of different
conditions,
uh are focus,
you have to be able to do one thing,
patience,
you have to do it for a long period of
time, and frustration tolerance. You
have to be willing to get kicked in the
nuts or the face or whatever in the
gonads. There you go. That's That's
coed.
Um
for extended periods of time.
And so, I I say these things because
when I talk to entrepreneurs, they
always seek the tactics.
But, I can
this is going to sound
I have decent pattern recognition at
this point. I've talked to a lot of
entrepreneurs. And I can usually guess,
I'd say, what range of entrepreneur they
are
by how they behave.
And that's because
all businesses can get very big.
Not all entrepreneurs can get very big.
And it's because they can't stay
focused, they are impatient, they quit
too easily.
And that means that you do not lack
tactics, you lack character.
And I find that to be
really interesting. And so, the question
then comes, okay, well, if that's if
that's what's required, and I don't
think anyone's going to really argue
with me on this. Like, yes, I should be
more focused. Yes, I should be more
patient. Yes, I should be more
long-suffering, enduring, being able to
continue
um
when when things become frustrating. I
don't think anyone's really going to
fight me on this.
So, the question is, how do you do it?
And so, I think
taking a different perspective of
if I were the worst or the most
dangerous competitor, somebody who I
would not want to compete against, what
would that person do in my specific
situation?
And interestingly, when you I think it's
like called third-party bias or there's
some some fancy psychological term. But,
basically, when you when you are not
trying to live your life through your
own eyes,
and you try and give someone else
advice,
you give way better advice than you
follow for yourself. And so, like, why
is this? And I think this is called the
Solomon paradox. There we go. Um
but we give better advice than we adhere
to because we do not have an emotional
tie to the situation.
And I think that that is kind of that
robotic thing that I was referencing
earlier, which is like
as much as Hollywood and the movies
always try to make it seem like, you
know, uh these humans against the robots
and then the humans somehow pull it out
in the end. It's like, no, like, try
have humans go against uh robot and just
and humans lose literally and I would
imagine that in cockpits for, you know,
airplanes, like, humans will lose
against AI, you know, fighter plane
fighter planes, right? Like, it's not
it's not reality to think that we're
going to we're going to win. Like, we do
a memory contest, computers win, right?
And so,
the idea is that um
the things that are that it takes to be
successful in business does not
necessarily make you more human. And so,
I think that is that is kind of like an
interesting notion. Um we have to behave
more logically. Um
and I would say this, if your emotions
encourage you to take an action and that
action is aligned with logic, then
great. But it's not the emotion that
caused it uh to work. It's just that the
logic was was valid and it was just also
aligned with how you felt. But being
able to make the correct decision
independent of how you feel, I think is
where it becomes more difficult. And so,
this is the kind of tactic um that I'll
share with you, which is
um embracing emotional discomfort and
not
making the fact that you were
uncomfortable, in pain, frustrated, have
this feeling, this itch to take action
on something because you feel bad,
because you want to change how you feel,
you feel like you need to change your
business and that in changing your
business, it's going to change how you
feel on the inside. Now, you taking
action often times does alleviate
anxiety, but it doesn't mean that the
action was still correct because it
might take time for us or or for that to
to to play out, right? And so,
while you're while you're in it, you
feel better, but then you look back at
the carnage or the the rubble of of you
breaking your business yet again and and
shifting your team's focus and said,
"Well, they said it was this priority
last week." And then the next week it's
the this next priority, right? It's that
you're constantly whiplashing everyone,
including your customers, which more
realistically looks like very confused
messaging and marketing, which means
that you stand for nothing because no
knows cuz you change your mind all the
time, right? And so, and that's because
you're reading an article or you watch a
video or whatever and it's like, "Ah,
actually that's this is the most
important thing." And so, you you have
to be able to stick with things for an
extended period of time and not start
new projects, um so you can see things
through because fundamentally like
all great things come from doing more
work in a very narrow place that other
people are willing to do.
Super real.
I think about it like, um
surface area of thinking.
How how much time have I given
this idea? How much air? Like how how
many how many coats of paint have I put
over this problem where I walk away and
I come back and look at the paint, make
adjustments, go back, look at the paint.
And the reason I think this is important
is that like over time
you're in different moods, you talk to
different people, you you look at that
painting with different eyes, different
lenses, different perspectives,
different things you're comparing it to.
And the more diverse
the lenses that you look at a solution
through, the more complete and elegant
the the solution will come. And that
only comes from having that many
repetitions over periods of time
on a specific problem. And when I say
specific problem, it doesn't have to be
just a problem in the business, it could
be the business as a problem as a whole.
And
I think that is why the people who are
unfocused do not necessarily win. And to
be clear, this is actually less a
question of intelligence. This is why I
say this is this is a character trait
issue. Like, um
a focused fool will beat a distracted
genius.
Men with focus will beat the men with
intelligence.
Real.
And so,
in thinking about that,
one,
how
can a How can I behave this way? Which
is What would the most dangerous
competitor in my place do? Let's do
that. Number one. Number two, if I feel
an emotion,
am I Is the action I'm taking to try and
make this emotion go away, or is it what
my business needs me to do? And those
are often not the same thing. More often
than not, what you need to do is keep
doing what you were doing, and just let
this
let this emotion pass. Cuz emotions are
like the weather. They come and go.
Right? And so, we have to sometimes just
give give them time, give them space,
acknowledge they exist. Great, I feel
you, and I'm going to continue doing
this thing.
Um
And then finally,
laddering up to those big three, those
big three character traits, patterns of
behavior.
Am I
this this new this second business that
I'm considering, this second revenue
line, this new idea that I have, is it
really required? Is there anything that
that logically stops my existing
business from doing twice as much or
five times as much or 10 times as much
besides the fact that it's quote hard?
I somehow think this other thing is
easier because I haven't done it yet,
but I promise you, it will also be hard.
And so, it's just unknown hard versus
known hard. And so, you just take
unknown hard.
Don't do that.
Like take known hard.
In terms of patience, the patience I
think is um
is giving yourself that surface area of
thinking. Is being able to have
multiple coats of paint over the same
problem and come back and revisiting it
with different perspective and different
eyes.
And then finally, the frustration
tolerance component is
am I able to sit with discomfort
and continue to take the actions that I
thought I should take before my emotions
tried to convince me that they were
inconvenient or incorrect.
And so, um
just something to think about on this
Sunday as I just review the week and I
think about some of the conversations I
had with different entrepreneurs and how
almost none of them They were all
seeking tactics, but what they really
needed were traits. They needed to
change the way they acted in their
business because it didn't matter what
tactics I provided, they were never
going to scale because they are not the
type of person who can.
So, yeah.
Happy, uh, whatever day you're watching
this on. Rock and roll. Bye.
If you like this video and you're
business owner who wants to break
through your current revenue ceiling, I
distilled every lesson from scaling 10
businesses past 10 million and three
businesses past 100 million into a
completely free scaling road map that
I've used to go from zero to one, zero
to 10, and zero to 100 plus. And so, you
can click here and you can check it out.
Again, absolutely free. And since you're
business owner, appreciate you and, uh,
enjoy.